aujourd'hui un voyage sans passeport
déjeuner à la carte le zoulouland et ses
réserves de chasse un superbe album
d'image qui va s'ouvrir dans un
battement d'aile au bord du lac de
sainte lucie un estuaire des îles
d'aimer embrun lagon enfin de vastes
étendues noyer forment l'essentiel du
décor
battus et rebecq par d'innombrables
compagnie des oiseaux qui règne de
travaux sur un domaine de 52 mille
hectares
aidons-le empire n'est pas contestée on
ne dira jamais trop de bien des réserves
de chasse où il est pratiquement
interdit de chasser
les lagunes s'étend sur 80 kilomètres et
largeur varie de 1 à 8 km c'est la plus
grande nappe d'eau sud du zambèze une
barrière de dunes où poussent des figues
et sauvage des noisetiers des acajous la
séparent de la maire qui lui veut pas
bien ici
les animaux vivent à l'état nature mais
en liberté surveillée et apparemment en
bonne intelligence
étant entendu qu'il mette rigoureusement
en application le manger vous les uns
les autres qui est l'article premier de
ce que françois mauriac appelle la
grande loi de l'antre des normands
universel si l'on trouve encore des
hypothèses à sainte lucie qui en compte
plus de 400 c'est grâce à l'énergique
décision du parlement natale qui décida
un jour de mettre fin au massacre auquel
se livrent des trafiquants qui
n'hésitait pas et tu essaies gigantesque
des animaux pour leur extraire dedans et
6 350 espèces d'oiseaux peuvent
aujourd'hui faire le bonheur des
ornithologues et en plus mais les arbres
qui mieux mieux c'est parce qu'il a été
remédié à l'envasement de l'estuaire qui
avait fait fuir les oiseaux et notamment
les cigognes en villégiature hivernale
vers des régions plus nourricière les
travaux terminés les oiseaux revint
inspecter leur domicile d'une pâte
prudente
puis ce fut la grande foule le
débarquement en masse
l'invasion des escadres y déployer
tél
on dit que sainte lucie est le paradis
des pêcheurs à la ligue et celui ci
croit bien avoir gagné son ancien des
îles à compter sans la présence d'un
concurrent parfaitement déloyal
le pélican qui pêchent au deuxième degré
mais tout aussi efficacement qui se sert
de son bec comme d'une tirelire pour
dissimuler ses larcins
ici l'aventuré sans danger il y à des
guides qui savent distinguer un rocher
d'un hippopotame
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas tellement
difficile l'hippopotame se signale lui
même par de grands jets d'eau boueuse
quant aux crocodiles qui rampent sur les
coudes à la manière du fantassin sous
les barbelés
on le protège aussi soigneusement que le
reste de la création pour la bonne ray
pour la zoologie
en fin de compte pour la peau
quant aux touristes il va sans dire
qu'on les garde aussi très attentivement
on ne sait jamais il y aura peut-être un
jour sur la terre conquise par les
ordinateurs des réserves d'êtres humains
les sages de leur faire visiter dès
maintenant leurs nouveaux pensionnés
m
dans les plages la mer sculpté taille le
rocher à son gré il faut il dire qu'elle
a beaucoup de talent
les plages ne sont désertes quand
l'apparence et dans les cavernes et
chauve souris mène une existence bruyant
plus souvent à l'envers qu'à l'endroit
pendus au plafond dans une bousculade 2
sec de pont qui rappelle le métro aux
heures d'affluence et malgré les
séminaires volubile qu'elles tiennent
sous les voûtes obscur de leur caverne
les chauves souris n'ont toujours pas
résolu le problème de leur double
appartenance
mais le cercopithèque lui a résolu le
problème de son évolution il est il
restera toujours là un singe il est
clair qu'il a renoncé à être un homme
malgré la tentation c'est trop difficile
ou bien c'est trop risqué
les gardes de la réserve ont également à
charge de protéger la flore de sainte
lucie ces plantes bulbeuses l'amaryllis
leuglay la fleur de sang
et voici dans l'ordre la grenouille de
roseaux cabochons posé sur un fil le
place au bâtonnet insectes qui trompe
son monde en simulant les pailles dans
lé vent régnié cornu la fourmi ouvrière
qui aménage avec tard d'heure son
domicile fut le scorpion régal du
babouin qui après l'avoir débarrassée de
son aiguille on s'en fait une sorte de
plats d'écrevisses
quant à cette sorte de mobiles qui n'a
que quelques centimètres qui semble
avoir été créé par la nature pour
devancer la sculpture moderne c'est une
mante religieuse elle se prépare à
mettre fin à l'existence d'un papillon
s'est passé antérieur immobilise sa
proie dans les ailes tombent comme les
feuilles mortes
et voici de nouveau l'habitant le plus
volumineux de sainte-lucie l'hypothèse
il vit presque toujours dans l'eau et
peut rester en immersion fort longtemps
il a de 4 à 5 mètres de long et son
poids c'est non sans tonnes il en fait
debout
si vous avez le goût de la chasse vous
n'avez pas le droit d'ignorer que
l'hippopotame n'est pas un glorieux
trophée comme il est presque toujours
immergé il est facile lorsqu'il fait
surface de le tuer depuis la berge en
logeant une balle dans son énorme tête
de préférence entre l'oeil et l'oreille
l'ivoire de ses dents et très estimé
une tête peut en fournir 7 kg le
problème comme dans toutes les affaires
criminelles et de dissimuler du cade art
essai 1993 qu il
les hippopotames ne quittent leurs plans
d'eau pleine nuit pour aller pâturer
tout au long de leur piste
ce sont de braves animaux végétarien qui
a quelques-uns sont capables d'engloutir
3 tonne d'herbe fraîche en une nuit
l'hippopotame me rumine pas mais il
bâille
à moins qu'il ne cherche témoin de la
préhistoire à expliquer quelque chose
aux hommes qui croient tout savoir et
qui ne l'écoutent rompt pas